SIERRA: So, the Why It Matters team, like
everyone else, is home, and it’s hard, things
are scary.I don’t know about you, but I have
been having endless video chats with my friends
and family. And, aside from drinking wine while
showing off completed puzzles or homemade bread,
we’re mostly talking about two topics. Health and
the economy. We bounce back and forth. What starts
as a question about how someone is feeling turns
into an update about who lost their job. These
conversations are happening everywhere - nobody
wants to get sick, nobody wants to lose their job,
and it can feel like it’s one or the other. As
people deal with these worries, some politicians
and business leaders have called for a return to
work in order to save the economy - even at the
expense of lives.It just keeps coming up, and
so we decided, hey, let’s pick up the phone and
ask two of our fellows to help us understand
the problem. One an expert on health, and the
other an expert on the economy. Just a heads up
that this episode is going to have a different
style than our other shows. It’s essentially two
conversations without most of our usual music and
narration and pizzaz. Don’t worry though, we’ll
be back to our regular format, and non-coronavirus
programming, for our season two premiere in
two weeks. But for now, I’m Gabrielle Sierra,
and this is Why It Matters. Today, saving the
economy and saving lives...do we have to choose?
SIERRA: Ok, first up Tom Bollyky. Senior
fellow for Global Health at the Council.
He’s getting a lot of these calls, so
hopefully he’s not tired of answering.
Tom Bollyky, how are you?
BOLLYKY: I’m okay, you know, grappling
with the shutdown like everyone else.
SIERRA: Yeah, what is your work from home
situation? She asks while sitting in her closet.
BOLLYKY: So, he answered while sitting in my
bedroom. Well, we have three small kids, so you
know, that's a challenge. And we live in the city
of D.C, so there is no great backyard for them
to run around in. So they bounce around the house
more or less like excited molecules at this point.
SIERRA: So we have officially made it to April.
Felt like we would never get here. Longest March
on record, I believe is the expert opinion. Do
you think April's going to be worse than March?
BOLLYKY: April in the United States will
definitely be worse than March. That's
because by and large, it takes about three
weeks for people to start showing clinical
symptoms. So starting to get physically
ill from having contracted the virus,
it spreads, as everyone knows
at this point, exponentially,
with a lot of the cases occurring among
people who have unreported infections.
SIERRA: So I want to ask you about something
that I keep seeing people arguing about on
social media, even though I'm trying to avoid
some of this stuff pretty, pretty hard. But,
do you feel like we have to choose between
saving the economy and saving lives?
BOLLYKY: No, I think saving lives or more
specifically keeping people from getting
infected is really the only way to save the
economy. The reality of this is, is that we
are not going practically to be able to go back to
work until we get this back under control. So the
best economic policy we have is health policy at
this moment. We can have a bad economic impact of
this pandemic with good policies, we’ll still end
up there, or we could have a much worse economic
impact of these with bad health policies, plus
all the lives lost. And, I choose the former.
SIERRA: But I've heard people say that if
we don't spend money saving the economy,
many more lives could be lost in the long run
due to recession. So do recessions kill people?
BOLLYKY: They do. Recessions do kill
people. There have been a number of
studies that looked at the great recession.
We saw health impacts, particularly for men,
and racial and ethnic minorities, and it ranged
from a lot of our diseases of despair that
exists out there already, in terms of suicide or
alcohol or substance abuse, traffic fatalities,
safe harm, declining fertility, you name
it, you see that in recessions. And we
just saw it a dozen years ago. So we're going
to see that again. But again, the option here
is not preventing a recession by allowing
this virus free reign to run rampant. It's,
do we want this to be a shorter recession or do
we want this to be a deeper and longer recession?
SIERRA: So the idea is to focus sort
of on the immediate and the short term,
and that will help, naturally, the long term.
BOLLYKY: Absolutely. You know, China is
starting to head back to work. South Korea,
which had its first case the same day
the United States had its first case,
is back to work. You know, we can do this. We got
off to an awfully slow start. But it can be done,
and the sooner we can do it, the better for us,
both from an economic and a health perspective.
SIERRA: So I've read that half the national
stockpile of ventilators has already been
sent out, which sounds really scary. So if
we want to stimulate the economy and fight
the pandemic at the same time, I don't really
understand why we can't put more people to work,
making masks, the protective gear,
the ventilators, the things we need.
BOLLYKY: So we can, but you know,
we need to mandate this. There are
going to be still supply chain issues
about can we make all the components,
can we get all that? But you know, we can
manage that. What is difficult to manage is
to be doing this in April instead of doing
it in January, February, even early March.
SIERRA: So what choices has the
US made in situations like this
in the past? Are there any past
success stories we can emulate?
BOLLYKY: Yeah, so in the past, in World War II and
in the Korean War, we granted the executive branch
broad authority to regulate industry so that
we could ramp up supplies that are needed for
the nation’s defense, we are in that kind
of moment. Now the president is talking
about doing that this week on a limited basis
and that’s great and I'm glad for it and we
should. But we are awfully late for this wave.
But here's one thing I do want to emphasize,
unfortunately, is that even when we get this under
control, this isn't going away. This is just the
first wave of this. Now if we can manage to get
ahead of it, we can do what some other nations
have done, which is to have good surveillance
and testing and really minimize the effect of
future waves. But until there is a vaccine, or
a really effective therapeutic set can reduce
people from getting sick from this, we're
going to keep seeing waves. At this point,
there are more than a million cases globally.
It's a virus that isn't going to go away.
There's no sign that it's going to go away with
weather, so ramping up production is good for
those second waves. I just wished we had done
it earlier, so it was good for this wave too.
SIERRA: So has the timeline on
a vaccine become any clearer?
BOLLYKY: So, it's a year and a year and a
half away. That's what we're looking at.
The other thing to know about the vaccine is
once we have it, we still have to make it in
the kind of volumes that can address people's
needs. You know, how do we do that? But even
once the vaccine becomes available, it'll
take a little time for everyone to get it.
SIERRA: So I shouldn't be pinning
all my hopes to that vaccine, huh?
BOLLYKY: Not in the short term. In the long term,
I'm a believer in human innovation. What I do
think you need for that to have its effect is
a realistic and honest assessment
of the challenges we face and the
urgency in addressing them. But when you have
that, I, you know, fundamentally believe in us
to have that innovation to address that. We just
need to mobilize it sooner than we have been.
SIERRA: What does the end game of
this pandemic look like to you?
BOLLYKY: The medium term, and people should
be honest about this, so I'm gonna try to
be in this podcast, is that you know, even in
the countries that have done well with this,
they're still seeing cases. They get
cases from people returning from abroad,
with infections like sparks, you know, you
need to control before they set off a wildfire.
That's going to be the reality for
a year or two years with this virus,
that we will have that risk. So this is not going
to immediately go back to the way it was. That's
the medium term of this. The long term is there
are only really two, either we develop a vaccine,
or at least 60% of the population needs
to become immune. The challenge with the
latter route is it will come at a great human
cost. So I would like to bet on the former.
SIERRA: I guess this is a hard question to answer,
but do you see any silver linings in all this?
BOLLYKY: Let me put it this way. Pandemics
put a mirror to the societies they inflict
and what they expose about ourselves
in terms of our vulnerabilities,
in terms of the limits of our health systems,
in terms of the dysfunction of our politics
in the past those have spurred reforms, whether
it's the building of our public health systems
or the construction of our great sanitation
networks in cities. All these came as a result
of past pandemics of cholera, or tuberculosis and
the like. We will have those opportunities here.
We will not be better for having experienced
this pandemic. It could affect as many as 40
to 70% of the world's population. We will not
be better off for having had that experience,
but we will have an opportunity at the end to
at least learn from it, and I hope we take it.
SIERRA: Thank you so much. I hope you and
your family are, you know, good, and don’t
drive each other crazy, but take these moments
to be together, and yeah, that you stay safe.
BOLLYKY: Thanks. You too. Take care.
SIERRA: So, according to Tom, we don’t
have to choose between saving lives and
saving the economy. For the time being
they’re the same thing - the best way to
help the economy is to stay home and prevent
infections. And that’s a hard pill to swallow.
What’s good for the economy as a whole
has real costs - people lose their jobs,
businesses fail. So, to understand the best
way to contend with this double-edged sword,
we decided it was time to call someone who
has spent his life thinking about the economy.
SIERRA: Sebastian Mallaby, hello, how are you?
MALLABY: Hey, Gabby, I'm great. I'm in London.
I’m in what my wife calls a cross between a
multigenerational Victorian family because
we've got three generations. My dad, us,
two teenagers. It's a cross between a Victorian
multigenerational family and a We-Work
because we're all working away at different
desks, at different parts of the house.
SIERRA: It definitely sounds like a full house.
So for the people at home, which I guess is
everyone right now, including you and me. Can
you just tell me what you do for the Council.
MALLABY: I work at the Council on Foreign
Relations as a senior fellow focusing on
international economics. And
so I follow what's going on
in the global economy and I've written
some books on the history of finance.
SIERRA: So I am in New York City and
I would be remiss if I didn't ask you
about the UK. How is it feeling
there? What's going on right now?
MALLABY: Well, we're in lockdown just like
in New York. So everybody's supposed to stay
inside their house from nearly all the time. You
are allowed out to take your one daily outing,
to do some exercise for up to an hour.
You can go for a walk or a bike ride. We
go on walks because the weather's been
pretty great. And London can often be
crowded and polluted, but right now it's
not polluted and it's not crowded. So,
you can have a very nice kind of
exploration of this historic city.
SIERRA: So, here in the US there's
been this push to go back to work and,
you know, despite the virus and to fight
through and save the economy. I mean,
do you think that we have to choose between
saving the economy and fighting the virus?
MALLABY: I think that for now we don't have to
choose because whether you are thinking about
the economy or thinking about public health.
You would choose to lock down and to try to get
this pandemic under control. I think, Gabby,
the tough decision is going to be, not now,
but in two or three months from now when the
virus has moved on, you know, some people will
have gotten it, and therefore, so long as they've
survived, they're going to be immune.And the more
people who are immune, the less it's obvious
that it's worth telling everybody to isolate.
You see what I mean? So I think as time goes by,
we will reach a point where it'll be fair to say
people should go back to work, even though you
haven't eliminated all of the public health risk.
SIERRA: I know here in the US I've been reading
that the government is going to be sending money
to individuals and to small businesses. So how
does this actually work? What's the goal there?
MALLABY: The goal is to try to keep
everybody afloat so that when the virus
finally plays itself out, and maybe we get
a vaccine, you know, a year or so from now,
people will be able to go back and resume their
lives with as little damage as possible. You
don't want people to incur enormous debts so
that when the virus has gone they're still
desperately financially underwater. You
know, this is an enormous financial hit
it will be the worst recession, the
deepest recession since the 1930s,
it will be much worse than 2008, 2009, in terms
of the reduction in economic activity, because
you know, we're in a medically induced economic
coma, you know, most people are being told, do not
work, do not produce stuff, do not be economically
active. And when that happens, of course,
economic activity will collapse. So, you know, the
economy is going to shrink by 20 or 30% month on
month in the second quarter of this year. And
that means that to get through that quarter,
when people are not earning money, you need to
spend savings. Many Americans don't have savings,
so then they would have enormous hardship. And,
if the ones who do have savings spend all those
savings, they're going to be in a weak state
afterwards. So it's better for the government to
give them money and for the extra debt that you're
creating because of this massive recession, that
that should be public debt rather than private
debt, because the public sector, the government
is going to be better at managing that debt and
paying it back and surviving despite the debt.
SIERRA: But I mean, is a one time
payment enough to accomplish those
goals? That seems like a lot with one installment.
MALLABY: No, you're right. I mean, I think it's
gotta be more than that. And I believe that,
you know, come May or thereabouts, you
know, I wouldn't be surprised to see
Congress pass the supplemental stimulus
to give additional help to people.
SIERRA: I was in New York during
9/11 and I remember the big push was,
you know, spend money, support the
economy, support your local places.
Is that sort of the ideal situation
with your stimulus check now too?
MALLABY: The classic line was, you know, come
to New York, watch a movie, go out to dinner,
stay in a hotel. Now you've stimulated the New
York economy and you've paid it back for 9/11.
Now you can't, right, because the movie, the, you
know, Broadway shows are closed, the restaurants
are closed, and the hotels pretty much aren't
operating either. So we have a simultaneous hit,
both to demand, in other words, spending is
going down, but also certain types of supply
aren’t there either because businesses are
closing down, they can't operate. So I think
the money this time is less about go off and spend
it. It's more about take this and try to survive.
SIERRA: So a lot of people are losing their
jobs. I know I have several friends and many
more that are going to face job loss and
everyone's filing for unemployment. So is
the US going to run out of money to pay all
these people for their unemployment benefits?
MALLABY: You know, that's a great question,
Gabby. It gets into a very, very interesting,
experiment that we're going to be running in the
next few months. If you think back to 2008, one of
the amazing policy surprises was that the federal
reserve could create unlimited amounts of money
and use it to bail out the financial system.
And there was no apparent penalty for that.
In the past, you would have said, hey, if the
Central Bank just prints money, you're going to
get inflation. This time there was no inflation
and without inflation, there was no reason that
the Central Bank should stop printing more money,
and it carried on doing so-called quantitative
easing where it basically creates money and pumps
it into the economy. It went on doing that for
quite some time after the 2008 crisis. So suddenly
we had this realization that Central Bank power
was way bigger than we had suspected before.
Now this time we're running the next experiment,
which is about government budget power, the
Treasury's power to have payments to American
families and American businesses
almost without limit. Can that be
done in the way that Central Bank money
printing was done almost without limit?
Now, there are a lot of economists who think yes
right now because inflation is nowhere in sight,
therefore, the Central Bank can create money and
it can use that money to buy government bonds.
And when the Treasury sells government bonds to
the Central Bank, the Treasury gets lots of cash
and it can give that cash to Americans freely. And
this process could continue really to an enormous
extent. And there will not be inflation, there
will not be a crash in the dollar, there will not
be any adverse consequence. And so you have this
sort of free license to basically create money.
SIERRA: Well, what's the potential downside
to that? That kind of sounds a
little bit too good to be true.
MALLABY: It does sound too good to be
true. The downside is that government debt
will increase. But the mitigating
thing is that the government debt
will be owed to the Federal Reserve, which would
have bought the debt, and the federal reserve
is ultimately part of the government. So the
government would be kind of owing money to itself,
and so that isn't actually terribly damaging.What
happens is the government has a bunch of debt.
The Treasury has to pay interest on that debt.
It pays the interest to the owner of the debt,
the owner of the debt is the Central Bank,
the Central Bank collects all that interest,
and under the rules of the Central Bank,
it pays back its profits, guess where,
to the Treasury. So the Treasury basically pays
the money to the fed and gets it back from the
fed, and it's a wash. So it is very much like
alchemy. You are printing money out of nothing.
It's creating gold by magic. So it's kind of
weird, but it's one of those things where,
you know, if you think about it carefully, you
can't think of a reason why it wouldn't work,
so long as people are okay with it. Of
course, if everybody decided to panic all
at once and run away from the dollar and buy
gold or Bitcoin, then the dollar would crash
and we would all be in trouble. But I don't think
that's going to happen. So I think we may discover
that you can increase government debt
without it actually crippling the economy.
SIERRA: I mean, it seems like it's worth
a try, at least in a situation this tough.
MALLABY: Right. Because we have
certainty about the cost of not
helping people out, that they
will be real human hardship.
And we have uncertainty about the economic
consequences of racking up a lot of extra
government debt. And so I agree with you, it's
an experiment that we should be willing to try.
SIERRA: Nice, so I can take at least one of my
immediate worries off my long list. Not worry as
much about that specific thing and just focus on
everything else that is continuously worrying me.
MALLABY: I'm glad I've given you a silver lining.
SIERRA: Thank you for that relief. So, you know,
I am an eternal optimist even in the face
of, you know, what's going on right now. Are
there any other silver linings that
you sort of see coming out of this.
MALLABY: So on Saturday, my sister had a birthday
and she lives about a half hour walk from my
house, so I cooked up a plan where I went on my
walk, my other sister came on a walk too. And,
we brought our kids along and a big banner that
said happy birthday in huge letters and some
gifts, and we put the gifts on the doorstep, and
then we retreated a safe distance and called my
sister on cellphone. And when she opened the door,
what she could see was the gift down on the steps
in front of her house and the big banner, and we
were all safely distant and, you know, medically
obedient to the public health rules. But we did
manage to have a family birthday celebration.
SIERRA: Oh, I love that. It was my
father's 65th birthday on Friday. And,
we sent food delivered and I had put like
a little note and the local restaurant,
they sent him this big card and it was
signed by all of them, and you know,
it was just really lovely. So I guess we're doing
the best we can with these birthdays, right?
SEBASTIAN: I like your story.
SIERRA: Sebastian, thank you so, so, so much.
SIERRA: So, do we have to choose between saving
the economy and saving lives? Whether you look
at it from the economic angle or the health
angle, right now the answer is a clear no.
According to our experts, the best thing for the
economy is still to stay home, prevent further
infections, and keep as many people alive as
possible.But there will eventually be a time,
when the United States, and other countries, have
to make tough choices about when healthy people
should return to work. Even as additional waves
of the virus threaten to appear.In the meantime,
stay safe, be well, and we’ll see you soon.
Want to learn more? Visit CFR.org where you
can find show notes for this episode, and a
Coronavirus topic page that gathers all the
Council’s expert analysis of the pandemic.Please
subscribe on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, or wherever
you get your audio. We also want to hear from
you directly during these extraordinary times,
so send your thoughts to whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations. The show is created
and produced by Jeremy Sherlick, Asher Ross,
and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer is
Markus Zakaria, and our researcher is Rafaella
Siewert. Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor,
and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Original music was composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Special thanks to Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle
Sierra, signing off. See you next time!